vous et on va faire une interview mon
sens mais principe les simples steevy
doit répondre en mentant
alors y en a pour qui ce serait pas
difficile ici bien sûr un mais pour vous
c'est un petit peu compliqué vous êtes
tellement pur mon petit cochon civile
ça se passe comment avec ruquier très
très mal est fait souffrir
donc ça veut dire que ça va très bien
mais là il a choisi pourquoi alors ok
pour mon corps à tourner à 40
laurent qui tu aimes son humour très
vite ou alors la panique
là je crois que c'est pas un bon et 10
mois et stevie tu crois que tu auras un
molière un jour oui je pense ouais tu
sais qui c'est molière bien sûr pas du
tout
j'ai vu tu sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
rumeurs ont couru sur toi non à 6-6 non
mais si un jour ton fils d'annoncer
qu'il est hétérosexuel tu réagirais
comment j'aurais pas de fils steve hill
tu m'aimes pas du tout